hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 2022 FTX crypto cup
this is a rapid game between Magnus
Carlson on the white end and Hans Neiman
this is the game where Neiman afterwards
famously said the chess speaks for
itself it's a very high level game a
model game in my estimation out of this
opening of the Sicilian Defense and
variation
rossolimo attack
soon we're going to have the minor piece
and balance
soon black will be working with the
unopposed light Square Bishop whose
strength is only enhanced because of
White's decision on move 16.
it's at that moment White created a
long-term static weakness
namely a backward D3 pawn and black was
able to put his full weight on that one
weak point and force White
on the defensive
alright from here it's G6 castles
nothing
new out of this opening phase
this guy right here once challenged
should fall back to C7 and does
to do otherwise
for instance exchanging nights this
would help white in two ways
one
two
the open lines are nice for white
so in this game the Knight goes to C7
questioning the bishop
Bishop takes Knight black takes away
from the center
this guy is ready to roll
94 how to defend C5
in this game B6
is played knowing that I may have to go
uncastled
that's what happens in this game
Knight F6 hits
King f8
the Knight is basically poison
if you're capturing the Knight like this
no good
discover check white gets the piece back
and that's just that's not just any
piece that's your most important minor
piece your fiend kettled Bishop
black cannot afford to play in this way
so he must go uncasseled and now the
Knight falls back
if you want to as black still keep open
the option to Castle
you would have to make a different ninth
move
96 for instance this defends the pawn
and Knight F6 would simply be a blunder
now
Pawn takes Knight
Pawn takes Pawn is no longer a
discovered check
the problem though with having the
Knight on E6 is that this bishop is
staring at the back of the Knight
not the greatest view in the world
this guy would prefer to be out and
about
B4 the Knight is on E6
so in short
there's a coordination issue if the
Knight goes to E6 right now
in this game it is B6
Knight F6 King f8 Knight E4 to Tempe
have been invested in order for
black to go on castled White made these
two moves uncastled black king and now
black will have to invest three Tempi
before he has castled by hand
H6 King G8 King H7
okay from here black develops the bishop
and normally I would say it also pins
the Knight
not in this case though
in the game we have D3
and black replies to that with 96.
this pun is not free
I want to highlight a couple lines here
in the event
of a player you know if you play Bishop
takes E5 here
what is a reply by white
could actually take the bishop and say
I'm okay giving up the queen I'm going
to highlight two lines here one where
white obtains a completely winning
position and another where the game is
simply over
in 16 moves
look at these white minor pieces check
Knight takes C6 hitting the queen Knight
F6 clearance so that the Knight drops in
into E7 you have to give up the queen
and now we have attack
counter-attack counter attack soon
one of these two pieces will be one back
the material will be restored however
how do you as black get out of this
situation
a three-pointer is restricting your king
and Rook
completely winning for white
one slight tweak to this variation and
we could see checkmate let's say the
King goes right
chop here game over
normally
it's the Black Knights that are here but
what a pretty finish this one would be
that's checkmate
okay my point this is not a free pun
96 in this game Knight G5 Knights
exchanged black pinpoints the light
squares
trying to force doubled F Pawns
Rook E4 not so fast
interferes with that
doubling of the f-pawns
Bishop is hit now in this position in
the Lee Chess Masters database
there's a game from 2019 between Nils
grandelius and nihal sarin
sarin in this position captured the
Knight
and captured the pawn and eventually
white won this position you'll notice
that picking up this Pawn does give
white a lot of activity the major pieces
primarily spring to Life along this e
file
and in this more open position black may
find it much more difficult to get those
few Tempe in to get the king tucked away
Black's idea in this game is to not take
this Pawn to work around it
and in this much more closed environment
black will find it much easier to invest
the Tempe to get the king to safety
alright from here move 16 as mentioned
the big weakness is created at this
moment
Carlson goes with C4
so I want to spend some time at at this
point right here
first of all
why is C4 played
why not immediately react to this threat
what is maybe a train of thought white
had in this position
I believe C4 is played to stop black
from in some cases playing C4 himself
for instance
let's say white immediately reacted to
the threat
here's how we could maybe play as black
C4 would be a very good move in this
position C4 is desirable for black
because on one hand you're trying to
on double one of your
one of your Pawns
and also stabilize your queen
she's very good on D5 especially after
let's say a reply D4 this would be an
amazing position for black
Queen is amazing primarily because she's
so stable
how do you challenge this piece
so this is one reason I believe white
wanted to play C4 or played C4 now to
stop black from playing C4
and another is I believe white expected
to get rid of this weakness he's
obviously well aware that this is a big
weakness structurally
uh I believe he expected to get D4 in
successfully but D4 never came in this
game
and I believe white may have
underestimated this next move by black
in the game Queen E6 is played now to me
this doesn't come across as the most
natural move
more natural to me is Queen D7 where you
stay trained on the weak point
but
with the queen on E6 we'll notice a
couple key differences between these two
posts one is she stays trained on C4
from the E6 Square which makes it much
more difficult to play D4 successfully
and another is by staying off of D7 D7
is now available for
one of the black Rooks and the other
black Rook is going to be on d8 so a
battery is now available
to Black
and there's another Square also that
will soon open up for this queen
G6 is going to open up soon every
possible black piece that could be
directed on D3 is going to be directed
at D3
now
if the queen had fallen back to D7 in
this position how might play have
continued
how might white have successfully
played D4
rookie two
this guy would be poison
if you take with the bishop you're in a
pin
you could defend it temporarily but y
could always put a third attacker on it
this is winning for white
also taking with the queen is winning
because Rook D2
if you save the queen you will lose your
king
taking it out just a couple more moves
let's say in this position is black
you play
Rook to d8
white could follow with first H3 cutting
out Bishop to G4 ideas and now let's
just say black goes for this idea to get
the king into safety
King G8 Rook D2
let's say that one's in there King H7
here is a line where white can
successfully get rid of this half dead
Pawn that static weakness will soon be
no longer D4 break is in there
in short
C4 in this position I believe aimed at
stopping Black from playing C4 and he
had an eye on hopefully one day playing
D4 himself but D4 Never Comes
in this game it's Queen E6
Rook E3 H6 G5
this square has now opened up for the
queen
from here the Simple Plan
Target
D3 Pawn
H3 white has the flight Square
the black king is castling by hand
meanwhile white is playing on the queen
side looking for a break he gets that in
with B4
what should black do in reply to this
is
to sit
if
white takes yes you undouble the pawns
but you give this Rook some play
black says I don't mind taking on the
double isolated pawns I prefer not to
allow your Rook
any activity along the a file so this
isn't the greatest structure in the
world but they control some important
Central squares
and again
there's a big problem here on D3
Queen B3
battery is there and here we are has to
babysit
the D3 Pawn hit
three times
and well here's now a fourth
what do you do
91 not a fun move to play
but what else can you try this is
actually one of the last chances for
white to maybe
change things up a little bit here
enter in opposite color Bishop position
white has this as a move right here E6
with the idea to enter an opposite color
Bishop position
black is up the pawn things change a bit
here black is still for Choice it's
another path
for white considered one of the better
tries at this stage right here
is E6 instead of Knight to E1 91 in this
game though
and now comes H5
the Knight goes right back to F3
keeping pressure on G5 running in for
the capture on D3 right here would not
be a good idea for black
in the game H4 is played
if black is capturing on D3 right now
this queen is overloaded she has to
watch over G5 and D3
white would be led off the hook
if black captures on D3 right now
Knight takes G5 can follow and then
white captures here
even game
so
H4 in this position not so fast with the
capture here
from here Bishop H2
and now E6 so
excellent position for black really well
coordinated all of these points are
defended
these are the only two weak points but
even if you go after them as white
there's going to be a big problem
on your king side
in this game Queen C3 is played what I
had a look at is a move like Queen A4
targeting this looking to track this one
down next
how could black follow up in this
position could actually ignore these two
points
it says you could play Bishop H6
preparing an eventual G4 break
let's say queen takes Pawn
Queen H5
playing this straight away there's
Knight takes H4 this is going to be a
really strong move hitting the Knight
hitting the rook in general black would
really like to play G4 because this
would extend the scope of
the unopposed light Square Bishop any
anytime you can break down enemy pawns
that are on the same color Square as
your unopposed
Bishop it's usually good news for that
piece more diagonals more squares open
up for that piece
so
not a good continuation to go hunting
for Pawns
tough road ahead this is already a
winning position for black
we have Queen C3
and now a little maneuver by the bishop
it wants to get to E7 to watch over H4
so that black can play G4 successfully
it just happens to also watch over C5 if
that's
if some defense of that point is needed
in the game the Knight goes back to E1
and now comes G4 it's important G4 be
played right now
if you make one lazy move like Bishop to
E7
you'll notice Bishop E7 isn't needed
right now there's no longer any pressure
on H4 so this isn't this wouldn't be
accomplishing anything
but let's say black did play in this way
you're not going to be able to get in G4
because white could play F3 and there's
a clamp over this Pawn break
so this is very Timely
black plays G4 right now
this guy's happy this queen is happy she
is after all opposite the king
From Here pawn takes Bishop takes
F3 Bishop backs off
F4
gets right back on an active Square no
longer needed to go to E7
F4 is in the crosshairs from here Queen
A5
Queen G4 look at the coordination
or lack thereof coordination for black
perfectly coordinated
Bishop on H2 Knight on his back foot
rooks disconnected
both unprotected
big problems in the game Rook F3 there's
two pins now
this Rook is pinned and this Pawn is
pinned
and black is able to take advantage of
that with his next move and sure enough
it is by the unopposed bishop
Bishop E4
this game is essentially over Black's
going to be winning material
it picks up a
doubled Pawn there goes the exchange
and black continues to pry away at these
light squares taking advantage of the
pinned g-pawn
Queen F2 there goes the d-pawn
there goes the a pawn we got a passer
black is up the exchange and a pawn now
so plenty of ways to go about converting
this one
from here Rook E3
King F2 and one final move
Bishop takes F4
and Carlson resigns
if play continued from here what might
we have
Bishop takes Bishop
recapture if the King goes here you lose
the Knight
well even if you go here to save the
Knight it's no save because black could
take the Knight
and me pawn takes Rook with a skewer
there goes the queen
so this one goes no further Bishop takes
Pawn final move
of this rapid game
let's have a quick look at the tail the
tape on this one and we can see the
quality of play in this one
very high level
uh 91 accuracy for Magnus Carlson 97 for
Neiman and these mistakes that the
computer is pointing out for Carlson
really don't help us out so much
um it's already at a point where black
is pretty much winning
the issue is dating back really to that
moment that decision to play C4
so that created that big weakness that
and he wasn't able to play D4 and get
rid of his d-pawn Queen E6 was a really
interesting reply to the C4 move
eventually being able again to direct
every PC possibly could at the weekend
D3 Pawn
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye